- Les entreprises de croisières
aux baleines à Gaspé connaissent
une bonne saison j'''à
présent. Certaines, comme
les Croisières Baie de Gaspé,
remarquent une hausse de
la clientèle internationale.
MYRIUEUEUELLET, guide interprète
Croisières Baie de Gaspé
- Niveau touristes c'est sûr
que, cette année, c'est pas
autant haut que durant
la pandémie. La pandémie,
c'était comme exceptionnel.
Mais là, cette année,
on retourne un peu plus
à des nombres qu'on avait avant.
- Les touristes du Québec
et d'ailleurs au Canada sont
aussi au rendez-vous.
- J'aime la mer. Donc, on va
faire un petit tour en bateau,
puis on souhaite croiser
peut-être quelques baleines.
- Alors que les viurururs
répondent à l'appel,
les baleines ont, quant à elles,
été plus timides au cours
du dernier mois, ce qui a rendu
l'observation des mammifères
plus difficile.
- Toute l'équipe, on cherche
beaucoup. On sort en mer,
On commence nos recherches,
on cherche beaucoup. On couvre
beaucoup, beaucoup de mer pour
essayer d'aller les rencontrer.
- Contrairement aux années
précédentes, très peu de baleine
ont été observée au large
de Gaspé et dans les eaux
du Saint-Laurent en juillet.
Cette variation des populations
de ces mammifères est notamment
due à la recherche
de nourriture.
ROBERT MICHAUD, dir. scientif.,
recherche, mammifères marins
- Je pense que ci i i est
à retenir, c'est pas
que ce soit une bonne
ou une mauvaise nouvelle,
c'est que l'environnementdadadas
évaluent chaque année, lui,
varie beaucoup. Il varie
de plus en plus, et de plus
en plus abruptement. Et ça,
c'est un peu ce qu'on avait...
ce qu'on nous avait prédit
comme une des conséquences
des bouleversements climatiques.
- Les baleines devraient
être davantage présentes
dans les eaux du Saint-Laurent
en août et en septembre,
selon Robert Michaud.
Ici Marguerite Morin,
Radio-Canada, Gaspé